- Dude, there's so
much shit going on.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
("Snow Days" by Anthony Russo)
- [Gary] Good, how are you?
- [Manny] Have a seat.
- [Man] Gary?
- [Gary] Yes, sir.
- [Man] I just want
to say thank you so much
for doing what you do, man.
- [Gary] It's a pleasure.
- [Man] Thank you
very, very much.
(crosstalk and laughter)
- [Gary] My pleasure.
Handshake and a thank
you is more than enough.
It's what you do on a
snow day, you get a haircut.
So what happened
you got some good?
- Yeah. Five guys came over.
- [Gary] That's great.
- [Manny] From all over.
Phoenix, Brooklyn--
- Really?
- Westchester, Bermuda.
- Yeah.
- That's awesome.
- They said,
"Say hello to Gary."
- You're global, Manny.
- [Tyler] 4:30 or 5,
that one guy that (censored),
that guy and then this
guy (censored) (inaudible).
- No sugar, thanks brother.
- Mhmmm.
- Yeah, I'm just
gonna go with, yeah.
I think it's good.
Let's get me to
the office, what, 4:30?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
That's what I thought it was.
- [Gary] 4:30 to like...
- [Tyler] I have this
(inaudible) between--
- [Gary] Yeah. Yeah, agree.
So what about
the flight tomorrow?
Am I booked on it?
- [Tyler] (inaudible)
Three options right now.
- [Gary] How many people
are at the office you think?
- [DRock] More of
our team were there.
- [Tyler] I would say
a good portion are there.
- [Gary] Good.
I love snow days.
I like when the
world shuts down.
The problem is
everything's global now so
it's not really shut down.
How's it going, good?
Just started?
- Yeah, because of you
I have 160 followers.
- Better than zero.
- [Manny] Yeah.
- I used to have a
160 followers, too.
- [Manny] (laughs) I know.
- Everybody starts somewhere.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome, Manny.
Good haircut.
Always feels fresh.
The beard.
Shit, I have no money.
Can't pay you, Manny.
(DRock laughs)
Oh, I can do
credit card here, right?
- [Manny] Don't worry about it.
- [Gary] Get the
fuck out of here.
There's no way. No way.
No way. That's that.
- [Manny] Forget about that.
- [Gary] No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no
it's very nice, no.
Here.
- [Manny] Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome,
my friend.
("Snow Days" by Anthony Russo)
I think the biggest
thing that we have
to figure out is between
me, you and (censored),
you know, (censored) or any
other friends of this (censored)
you know like how
much can we get for free?
Question, we built
out the best social...
They're, I know that on the back
end if it's not tracking as well
as they want, oh,
actually you
know what, (censored)?
Here's actually
the right answer.
(censored), if you're following
this along I think one of the
things to keep in mind is to go
a different route which is the
(censored) is best used to
kind of make you guys crush it
'cause we want to sell out but
keep this in the back of your
mind as you allocate money,
if it is not as successful the
things we'll learn in those two,
here we are three weeks later
and it's not selling as well as
you wanted our paid efforts will
give us indicators on what's
working best and we may be able
to come back and say, look,
let's spend some more money
against these targets.
Let's not take that for granted
and let's be like methodical.
Exactly, exactly.
One of the other things is
I want to not only be successful
in what we're doing for them.
I want to be quite strategic
creatively around pushing
the boundaries so that maybe
(censored) above and beyond
actually succeeding in what the
business KPI is has an
opportunity to possibly,
you know, be put on a pedestal
by Facebook itself as best in
class sports kind of video
commercial of the year which
would then have impact
on (censored) going forward.
Maybe even giving (censored)
team leverage to signing a
longer-term deal with the
clubs or things that nature.
So, my ambitions for this video
are extremely high because the
upside is just so incredible to
my business partners who own the
(censored) and so
we need to really,
really think in
terms of innovative,
not only does it
have to be emotional,
but much like
the Sandy Hook PSA,
I think it needs
to shock people.
We need to be smart and try to
figure out how to like really,
really, really make an
impact above and beyond.
For me, really the Holy Grail
is not only does it succeed in
driving awareness and sell
(censored) but that it beats out,
it beats out (censored)
for best sports video marketing
asset of the year in whatever
circles to really bring the
(censored) to a
higher level as a brand.
("Snow Days" by Anthony Russo)
No, no you have to
dress like yourself.
Own, you own your thing.
I was debating with the book
coming out in January I have to
promote and just with the level
of fame that I'm starting to
build that the deal was,
I couldn't wrap my head around,
I knew it wasn't a great deal
but I really want to
do this with (censored).
Him believing in me kind of
drives me a little bit and
(censored) what I'm trying to
accomplish here is to go through
this contract and
business negotiate
it a little bit but
also make sure I don't make a
disproportionately bad deal in
case other opportunities come
but the fact of the matter is,
(censored), and you
know me for a long time.
My energy is probably to
smash the shit out of it so that
(censored) is put into a
position where they want to go
crazy into me and that the
success of it gives them the
financial ability to go
crazy into me going forward.
That's kind of the vibes. Cool?
What does that mean real life?
What are (censored)
gonna sell them for?
I assume small, go ahead.
- [Man] Yeah, everyone sort of
(censored) margin so if they're
repaying it
(censored) so (censored).
- Right, when you come out
and say wholesale (censored),
every retailer gonna go at
(censored) or are there gonna be
the (censored)? I assume
some people have sales.
What's the (censored) look like?
I mean the MSRP on wine was
$80 and bought at $40 and
Wine Library sold at $41.99
'cause I was a fuckin' savage.
("Misfit Anthem" by
Social Club Misfits)
What's happening?
Put a proper profile on it, put
up a piece of content and just
keep it maintained
so that we can continue
to be on the offense.
This is smart.
It's just a good idea.
Let's create, so let's do this.
Let's create a framework
for this conversation.
Here's what I'd like to happen.
I'd like to get a list of 10 to
15 things that we want the most.
("Misfit Anthem" by
Social Club Misfits)
You all good?
Love it.
The good news is I'm not too
worried about it in a micro.
Here's what I would say consumer
insights that are smart insights
are the gateway
to the best creative.
Hold on one second.
'Sup man?
- 'Sup man, how are you?
- [Gary] Good, you?
- Love your stuff.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
My intent is that you
get even more that over time.
Brother, we're gonna,
do you understand
what the fuck is going on?
- [Man 2] I just really wanted
to get a chance to speak with
you about a job opportunity.
- [Gary] At Vayner?
- Yes.
- DRock, get his
information right now.
- [Man 2] Very hungry,
very driven.
- [Gary] I'll set it up ASAP.
- I appreciate it.
- I love the hustle.
- Man, thank you.
- You'll be in
the office next week.
- That's sounds perfect.
- [Gary] Done.
- What you want to say, man?
- [Gary] You got
one fucking life,
don't bullshit it.
- There you go.
You heard it from the man.
Thanks a lot, boss.
- [Gary] You're welcome, bro.
- [Man 3] Take care.
- My man. Fuckin' DRock.
- [Gary] Let's do it.
Done. Done.
Done, it's probably not next
week 'cause of Europe but the
following week, you know?
Alright, get him
to New York, ASAP.
- [AJ] Yep.
- Dude, there's so
much shit going on.
("Caustion" by JMKM)
Good snow day,
good PureWow strategy sesh.
- It was fire.
- If you're not signed up for
PureWow's email
newsletter do it now.
Especially if you're
a 27-year-old dude.
- We'll take anyone.
- We'll take 'em all.
("Caustion" by JMKM)